[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il était une fois un petit garçon qui
vivait à l'orée du bois
le paysage était beau la vie était belle
bonjour
après une violente nidorage une grosse
tache rouge s'abattit au-dessus de sa
maison
qu'est-ce que c'est que ça c'est moche
et qui a-t-il pourquoi ça n'arrive qu'à
moi je n'ai rien fait il était fou
furieux il voulait tout casser
le rallongement
ça ne change rien la tâche était
toujours là
il pensait alors qu'il pouvait la gommer
et lorsqu'il essaya elle est encore plus
sale
finalement
il décida de la repeindre avec une
peinture blanche du coup ça faisait un
gros pâté au-dessus de sa maison mais au
moins la voyez plus
et la vie pouvait presque recommencer
comme avant
jusqu'au jour où une bouffée d'un vent
rapporta une nouvelle tâche au-dessus de
sa maison alors là il était dépité
il ne voulait plus utiliser la peinture
blanche
et avait presque la fondation de vouloir
tout déchirer pour ne plus y penser
histoire aurait pu s'arrêter là mais au
dernier moment il s'est dit non non ce
n'est pas possible il revient dans la
page si comme si la tâche n'existait pas
et qu'il ne s'était rien passé
la vie devenait à Naples
alors pour la première fois
va regarder la tâche
rois dans les yeux
et
ce que je vais bien pouvoir faire de toi
l'observant et finalement
d'une idée
décida de prolonger
et la tâche devant un soleil
trouver son idée géniale
surtout elle le rendait heureux
ce jour-là
il ne l'oubliera jamais
parce que c'est le jour où il a commencé
aimer sa tâche rouge
cette histoire elle a été écrite par
Pierre Hedrich
je l'aime beaucoup parce qu'elle permet
d'expliquer aux enfants qu'il faut vivre
avec ses différences
osez la résilience et que la vérité
d'aujourd'hui n'est pas celle de demain
et ce petit garçon c'était moi avant
avec mes peurs mes doutes et mes
croyances limitantes
jusqu'au jour où j'ai réalisé que
quelque chose qui nous fait du bien
passion
être un catalyseur qui change les
mécanismes de notre cerveau sur notre
façon de penser
dans les prochaines minutes je vais vous
présenter 7 mouvements pour surprendre
notre cerveau et passer d'un état
d'esprit fixe un état d'esprit en
mouvement
les annonces flammes mesdames et
messieurs je ne suis pas présenté je
m'appelle Abdelaziz Alami alias corona
et je suis danseur
[Musique]
réalité
de la même manière que nous avons tous
un cerveau
nous avons tous un talent
et donc cerveau ne font que le point de
départ
mais nous ne servent à rien nous ne
savons pas comment les exploiter
c'est à dire que
capacités les plus élémentaires peuvent
s'exprimer que à travers je dévouement
et du travail
le problème avec le mot que je viens de
dire à l'instant où la phrase que je
viens de dire à l'instant c'est le mot
travail
vient du latin tripalium qui était en
fait un instrument de torture utilisé
par les Romains à trois pieux pour finir
les esclaves
or la nature de notre cerveau
les flemmards
le cerveau il est fait pour nous
protéger contre quelque chose de nouveau
ou quelque chose qu'on ne connaît pas
on connaît tous le dicton moi j'en fais
je me porte
à l'inverse lorsqu'on exerce quelque
chose qui nous fait du bien
notre cerveau abaisse ses barrières
inconscientes
il accueille avec plus de facilité
la nouveauté le changement ce qui nous
procure
plus de bonheur
plus de créativité
plus de résidence
exemple
lorsqu'on va dire un bouquin
parce qu'on fait du sport
tout autre activité qui nous procure du
bien-être
à ce moment là on dit toujours je n'ai
pas vu de temps passé
ça a une passion
premier mouvement
découvrir
une étude menée par la plateforme
Opinion Way sur les passions des
Français révèle que
88% des Français ont une passion
et pas mieux
83% d'entre eux estiment qu'avant une
passion permet d'être soi-même
le problème c'est quid des 12% qui se
disent ouais mais moi j'ai pas de
passion
bonne nouvelle c'est qu'on peut tous
découvrir sa passion pour cela deux
ingrédients
replongez dans l'enfance période
insouciante et inconsciente et lister
sur papier
les choses dans laquelle on était bon
tous les points dans lesquels on était
fort
et même si ces choses ont évoluées
restent quand même un bon point de
départ
peut-être que si par exemple on aimait
la musique auparavant
retournez dans l'événement dans lequel
on aimait cette musique nous éclairer
peut-être qu'en fin de compte
mais passer du temps avec les gens
et auquel cas
évoluer dans de l'événementiel
aujourd'hui ça peut être un bon point de
départ
deuxième ingrédient
écoutez le feedback de nos proches
on le meilleur miroir sur les qualités
que l'on ignore sur nous sur le même
principe listez toutes les qualités
qu'il pense avoir sur nous toutes les
choses qu'ils pensent quel match avec
nos valeurs
on va pas se mentir si vous remarquez
bien à chaque fois que quelque chose
nous fait du bien une passion on a tous
un moment donné ce sentiment de retour à
la réalité
ces petites voix ces petites phrases qui
parasitent notre état d'esprit est donc
notre bien-être par exemple quand
quelqu'un va nous dire ah c'est sympa ce
que tu fais et qu'on lui répond oh tu
sais je le fais pour passer le temps
toutes ces phrases qui commencent
toujours par oui mais
toutes ces phrases négatives comme je ne
sais pas je ne suis pas capable jamais
en fait
lorsqu'on pense que tout est joué
d'avance que ça soit sur nos qualités
nos défauts de manière innée on finit
par développer une posture de
résignation
on croit qu'on n'est pas capable de
faire telle ou telle chose dans un
domaine et c'est ça qui crée des
blocages
deuxième mouvement
abolir
notre état d'esprit joue un rôle
fondamental parce qu'on fixe des
objectifs et même de manière générale
dans la réussite
je vous diffuser une publicité faite par
l'équipement de Nike au sujet du
basketteur Michael Jordan en fait cette
publicité elle est assez déconcertante
parce qu'elle met en valeur les échecs
de celui qui est considéré comme le
meilleur basketteur de tous les temps
je vous en dis pas plus je vous laisse
découvrir
[Musique]
en fin de compte ce qu'il faut retenir
c'est que en cas d'échec répété
la seule chose à faire pour abolir les
mécanismes de croyances limitantes c'est
de lister toutes nos petites victoires
aussi un film soit-elle ça peut être des
bonnes notes ça peut être des bons
résultats même des compliments aussi
parce qu'en fin de compte sur le cerveau
il faut sept actions positives pour
contrer une seule action négative
le cerveau il est beaucoup plus sensible
beaucoup plus réceptif beaucoup plus
proactif lorsqu'on lui envoie un message
positif sur le cerveau pour passer à
l'action
troisième mouvement
numéroter
dans ce qu'on a un plan d'action il faut
systématiquement le numéro T avec la
méthode des escaliers
à titre personnel j'y croyais pas du
tout
j'ai l'impression qu'elle me toucher moi
dans mon ego masculin dans ma capacité à
m'organiser
jusqu'au jour j'ai rencontré mon ami
Alex coach et mentor business aux
États-Unis et là ça m'a bluffé
quand divise une ambition en trois ou
quatre grandes étapes et dans chaque
grandes étapes on y met des sous parties
en fait te dire plus facile
je vous donne un exemple concret moi
dans ma timidité légendaire j'avais une
envie folle de danser me produire devant
un public
du coup pour ça je devais m'entraîner
trouver mon identité artistique
être à l'aise devant un public et
pouvoir susciter de l'émotion donc mes
sous parties c'était répéter mes
mouvements trouver le style de danse qui
me correspond m'entraîner chaque semaine
à parler à connu dans la rue et enfin me
poser systématiquement la question si je
suis pas danseur qu'est-ce que
j'aimerais bien voir quand je regarde un
danseur
je peux vous dire ça a changé beaucoup
de choses
on va pas se mentir vite tout à l'heure
je vous parle de travail d'énergie et
vous vous souvenez de ce que j'ai dit
tout à l'heure sur le cerveau
il est flemmard
d'ailleurs j'ai une question pour vous
lever la main ceux et celles oh le
public
respecte toujours les bonnes résolutions
qui prennent le jour de l'an
un grand monde
c'est normal
pour nous donner tous de plus de chance
de réussir face à une ambition il faut
mouvement numéro 4
signer un engagement dans le temps et
suivre son évolution
en neurosciences on dit que généralement
il faut 21 jours pour qu'une action
répétée devienne une habitude
Stephen King par exemple qui est un
auteur américain que qui a écrit une
soixantaine d'ouvrages à succès il note
systématiquement le nombre de mots le
nombre de pages qu'il écrit pour
s'autoréguler en cas de hausse de
productivité ou de baisse de
productivité ce qu'on appelle la
quantification de soi
cette quantification aujourd'hui on la
retrouve de manière beaucoup plus
vulgarisée soit à travers les
applications mobiles nos smartphones et
nous permet de pouvoir calculer à peu
près tout par exemple le nombre de pas
qu'on fait chaque jour
le nombre de calories perdues nombre de
temps que l'on passe sur les réseaux
sociaux ou encore
toutes les petites choses toutes ces
petites notifications qui nous permet de
nous rappeler des tâches qu'on a à faire
dans la journée
cette manière on ne perd jamais de vue
notre objectif et ça nous donne des
chances de pouvoir continuer vers notre
ambition
mais c'est vrai tous les jours on est
tiraillé entre bonnes résolution et
tentation et une étude du National
Public Institute révèle que en fait un
individu qui est capable de renoncer à
son plaisir immédiat pour un objectif de
bien-être futur c'est quelqu'un qui a
plus de chance de réussir dans la vie
5e mouvement
obstiné
lorsqu'on se lance un nouveau défi
n'hésite pas à en parler autour de nous
l'engagement social aide à maintenir les
habitudes plus on va en parler puis on a
des chances de les réaliser et puis on
sera obstiné
sur le cerveau en fin de compte ce qu'on
est capable de divulguer aux autres ça a
plus d'impact que ce que l'on garde pour
soi
et d'ailleurs lorsque par exemple on se
fixe un objectif et qu'on le rate on se
trouve toujours des bonnes excuses
et par contre il est plus difficile de
faire accepter ces mêmes excuses à son
réseau
quelqu'un qui prend l'engagement
d'arrêter de fumer devant son public
faut dire que le jour il glisse sa
première cigarette devant quelqu'un qui
connaît
elle lui fait tout bizarre normal
parce que le pouvoir de la volonté ne
sert pas seulement l'intérêt individuel
il sert également l'intérêt collectif
et oui c'est vrai cependant on va pas se
mentir travailler tout le temps pour
obtenir un bien-être supérieur sans
jamais profiter de l'instant présent ce
sera un peu une vision vraiment hâte de
la vie
c'est pour ça que je couds de manière
générale pour pouvoir perdurer lorsqu'on
fixe un effort dans la durée il faut
mouvement numéro 6
nourrir son engagement de petits
plaisirs
dans mon cas personnel
je me suis toujours dit si je me produis
devant 50 personnes je t'ai le chapeau
de mes rêves
or c'était chose faite j'étais tellement
content j'avais l'impression que le
chapeau il me parlait
et du coup lorsque j'ai dansé ensuite
devant 80 personnes j'ai acheté mon
deuxième chapeau
et au fur et à mesure que je dansais
devant un auditoire de plus en plus
élevé et bien je m'achetais de plus en
plus de chapeau au cours de la du
plaisir que ça me procurait mais
également
du bien-être tout simplement d'avoir une
grande collection ça m'a surtout mis
dans un cercle vertueux
et ce cercle vertueux c'est ce qui mène
à notre septième mouvement
le succès
en fin de compte
lorsqu'on est face à des difficultés ou
des complexes pensant toujours aussi
mouvement qui mène au succès
si vous remarquez bien depuis tout à
l'heure j'ai associé systématiquement
un mot clé à un mouvement parce que le
message est beaucoup plus fort à ce
qu'on envoie à notre cerveau
et aujourd'hui j'avais pris comme
engagement de vous faire danser
et pas de la manière que vous croyez
alors je vais vous demander si vous
plaît mesdames et messieurs
répétez après moi et de reprendre cette
mouvement je vais les faire dans un
premier temps et ensuite on les fera
tous ensemble
premier mouvement découvrir
deuxième mouvement abolir
troisième mouvement numéroté
4e mouvement signé
cinquième mouvement obstiné
sixième mouvement nourrir 7e mouvement
succès on va le faire tous ensemble
premier mouvement découvrir deuxième
abolir troisième numéroter quatrième
signer cinquième obstiné 6e nourrir 7e
succès
ces mouvements ce sont les miens
les mots clés ce sont les miens
parce que c'est mon histoire
et chacun d'entre nous a sa propre
histoire
chacun d'entre nous à ses propres mots
chacun d'entre nous à ses propres
mouvements
du coup dites-vous simplement que tout
est possible et en cas de coup dur
simplement penser à une chose
Terminator a pu devenir le gouverneur de
la Californie
alors on peut tous se sublimer
merci beaucoup et bonne soirée
[Applaudissements]